wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit der These von Michael nass den
Bestseller Auto der sagt er hat die
Lösung für Deutschland gefunden ich bin
gespannt naja die Lösung also das ist ja
die ähm das ist eigentlich eine
zwingende Geschichte
die Frage die man sich vielleicht auch
stellen wollte was vielleicht auch zeigt
dass hier viele Diskussion noch gerade
ein bisschen am Thema vorbei gegangen
sind ist ja letztendlich warum es seit
Jahren schon so viele Leute auf die
Straße treibt ja dann Journalisten gehen
hin und gehen auf dieser
unterschiedlichen
Illustration und stellen dann irgendwie
fest na ja es gibt dann so sehr
vielfältige Gründe aber es ist gibt es
gibt ein Grund der die meisten dieser
Leute vereint warum die da hingehen und
das ist das ist existenzarzt also alle
Krisen der letzten Zeit Energiekrise
coronakrise flüchtlingskrise da sind
alles im Grunde genommen Existenz Angst
kriegen die Leute haben Angst durch
diese Krisen sich ihr Leben halt nicht
mehr leisten zu können und darum das hat
übrigens Markus Lanz gesagt ist die
große und ich stimme ihm dabei ist die
große Frage die wir uns eigentlich
beschäftigen sollte die soziale Frage
und darum ist die Lösung für dieses Land
unbedingt kommen das Bürgergeld was
jetzt irgendwie da abgewunken wurde
finde ich jetzt auch finde ich gar nicht
so falsch dass es nicht so umgesetzt
wird weil es einfach nicht zu Ende
gedacht und nicht richtig durchdacht
wurde also bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen das ist die Lösung für
uns alle wir fragen doch mal den Politik
und Wirtschaft vom Bild direkt
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen ist dass
die Lösung für Deutschland na das ist
natürlich nicht aber das hast du jetzt
erwartet in deiner Frage und hat er nass
sicherlich auch erwartet aber ich glaube
das kann auch kein ernst gemeinter
Vorschlag sein bei der Frage wie wollen
wir dieses Land voranbringen ein Land
ist noch nie vorangekommen das zeigt die
ganze Evolution die man sagt ich gebe
dir erstmal was für nichts tun und
guckst du mal was dabei das ist ja genau
das ähm und ähm ich kenne die Argumente
von ihnen auch die vielleicht gerne noch
mal wieder ausführen aber das darum geht
es am Ende ja sondern es gibt und das
wissen wir auch ein Hunger der Menschen
nach Leistung nach Bindung und nach
macht das sind die drei Dinge mitmachen
uns nicht gefallen aber so sind wir
Menschen gestrickt und es gibt ein
Streben auch Dinge zu verändern Dinge
besser zu machen und weil sie das Thema
Bürgergeld gerade Ansprachen das sind
die Anreize die eine Gesellschaft auch
setzen muss denn am Ende bezahlt ja die
Gesellschaft mit ihren Steuern
beispielsweise dass Menschen nicht
arbeiten das kann eigentlich nicht im
Interesse dieser Gesellschaft sein schon
gar nicht wenn sie schrumpft wie wir
sehen also immer mehr Menschen ins
Rentenalter gehen und zu wenig junge
Menschen nachwachsen zu sagen und jetzt
kannst du erstmal mit dem Geld 1000 €
1500 im Monat machen was du willst und
ob du arbeitest oder nicht das stellen
wir dir frei das kann nicht Sinn einer
Gesellschaft sein die schrumpft und
schon gar nicht im Sinne vieler vieler
Menschen die das finanzieren wollen das
ist eher glaube ich eine Hängematte für
jene die keine Lust haben zu arbeiten
das ist natürlich diese klassische CSU
FDP
sagen die die Leute würden dann einfach
dann würde keiner mehr arbeiten also ich
würde sagen so ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen es geht nicht um
irgendwie 8000 Euro oder so Monat das
alle dann nichts mehr machen sondern es
geht einfach um eine Grundsicherung dass
ich nicht meine Entscheidung ständig
davon ab
es geht nicht ums Geld es geht um es
kommt ja immer darauf
ansonsten finanzieren also wenn Sie
meine Zahl die sich unter bedingungslos
vorstellen finanzieren also
das Geld aufbringen um einen Betrag 1000
1500 2000 € im Monat für 33 Millionen
Menschen unabhängig davon dass sie
gerade noch gesagt haben dass das auch
ein Problem wäre was die
flüchtlingskrise lösen würde das also
offensichtlich alle Leute nee kommt das
Geld bekommen was ist das Problem weil
die denken warum auch immer die
Flüchtlinge kommen hierher wird und bin
dann irgendwelche Geld aus irgendwelchen
Töpfen was ihnen dann eigentlich
zustehen würde was natürlich völlig
falsch ist denn das war da auch nie
vorgesehen nein es geht darum ich rede
von einer Grundsicherung aber das hat er
recht from in den 70er Jahren
müssen wir haben um zu wissen liegt an
den die Fixkosten die man hat hat
funktioniert das leider nicht also es
gab ja Experimente es gab Experimente
alle super funktioniert haben genauer
angeguckt die haben das ja alles
probiert es stellt sich heraus dass die
Produktivität runter geht das Problem
wird aber sein wir haben vielleicht
15 15 Millionen Leute die Steuern
bezahlen aus dem ersten heraus dann
haben wir noch mal ungefähr so viele die
kriegen das Geld vom Staat also die
Zahlen dann Steuern aus steuern das ist
nicht selbst erwirtschaftet wir haben
vielleicht zwei bis drei Millionen
Unternehmer die Leute
versicherungspflichtig anstellen und die
dann sagen wir insgesamt mit 20 25
Millionen Leuten arbeiten und die da
Geld verdienen und die ziehen sozusagen
hier ganz Deutschland durch
und ähm den muten wir dann zu dass sie
zusehen wenn sie selber nicht die Zeit
haben und mit ihrem Kind zu spielen weil
sie auf Arbeit gehen das andere die Zeit
haben weil sie von dem was sie an
Steuern bezahlen mitfinanziert werden
schalte das für außerordentlich
schwierig das wirkt sozialen Sprengstoff
aus der Güter und das Problem ist nun
mal es ist ein Industrieland wir können
uns das Geld gerne selber probieren wir
können das Geld gerne selber drucken
dann ist es aber nichts mehr gemacht
hat auch damit zu tun dass du gedruckt
wird wie geklappt da haben Sie Recht das
nicht der Punkt der Punkt ist bisher
galt es eigentlich dass der Kapitalstock
in Deutschland mit der Industrie stark
genug ist diese Schulden dann wieder
aufzuarbeiten das war bisher zumindest
bei den Märkten immer die Voraussetzung
weiterhin zum Beispiel den deutschen
Kredite zu geben wenn keiner mehr diese
Glaubwürdigkeit auf international
Märkten herstellen kann dann drücken wir
den sachsentaler und den Berlin Pfennig
und so ein Zeug und dann hat jeder diese
Geldscheine Behandlung kann davon nichts
kaufen
können wir so machen aber am Ende wird
niemand nichts haben
können sie trotzdem sagen sie dürfen
Antworten
ich kann da keinen Wert sagen ich kann
nur sagen dass der der ein Irrglaube ist
dass dann die Leute plötzlich nicht mehr
arbeiten gehen das haben die Experimente
aber anders gezeigt und wenn es in der
überlebende man kann auch Arbeiten
Leute die relativ wenig verdienen Sachen
du weißt wenn ich mit dem Bürgergeld und
dem bezahlten Wohngeld und der bezahlten
Heizung auf selbe ungefähr rauskomme
dann bin ich doch nicht bekloppt und
gehe noch arbeiten dann mache ich am
Wochenende schwarz weiß und habe noch
viel mehr auf der Tasche also das ist
doch absolutes Zeug was ihr gelabert
wird die Firmen die haben danach keine
Möglichkeit mehr mit den Mitarbeitern zu
arbeiten die Sie brauchen um produktiv
zu sein und Steuern zu bezahlen die
wahrscheinlich noch angehoben werden in
der nächsten Zeit um den ganzen sums zu
bezahlen warum haben wir den aktuell
gerade so ein handwerkerproblem die
Leute scheiden sich ja gar nicht die
scheinen auch keine Arbeitskräfte zu
kriegen gerade ja aber das hat einen
anderen Grund